define
what an anr does because i think that
people who are just watching this who
might not be involved in the music
industry they hear that term so much
they don't really understand what it is
so anr has multiple things that you have
to be good at
so a lot of people think a and r is just
hearing a song on a radio being like
that's a good
song or i saw an artist and he's dope
what people don't understand is once you
sign that artist
you have to help them put their project
together
right make sure that they have the right
songs to put out
then you have to deliver that album that
means get your artist to give you the
project to be like this is it
i'm ready to go in the public with it
right you know what i'm saying
jesus christ so
the hardest part of a r is getting your
artists to deliver their album you know
what i'm saying because their projects
their baby and a lot of time
artists are insecure with their music at
some points in it
and you know that's a big thing for you
no very vulnerable situation for
artists to give music to the world for
the world to critique them of course
um so you know just different levels of
of a r and you know the record-making
process
is is a big part as far as knowing the
right writers producers
and people just to put um in the studio
with them so you'll you'll come to the
table and say hey i think
uh this person would mesh well with this
person so like let's put you in with
this producer for
yeah and see what comes out of it
absolutely and you know
you have to be there in the studio with
them to make sure that you know because
they're not going to come and be like
best friends
right right you're kind of like you're
kind of the middle man yeah so you have
to make sure that everybody's
comfortable with the creative process
but you have to know the creative
process from both sides the artists and
the writers and the producers to make
sure that
everybody could come together you know
make magic together which is the hit
record